hello everyone and welcome to round
three of the 2013 candidates tournament
we have a game between Boris Gelfand and
Magnus Carlsen
as you've seen Hassan who drew his game
in round one and round two with iron and
Vladimir Kramnik now he faces gelfand
and we do have a photo of this encounter
here we have a guy from the left cousin
on the right and although this yeah this
is a photo of the third round but we
also must address the choice of
beverages so here we have Boris Gelfand
sipping on his little coffee well we can
only presume it's coffee but what else
would you drink out of such out of a
such a small mug and we have Magnus
Carlsen with whatever this is but I'm
sure it became a quite popular after in
the 2013 candidates tournament and also
we have a very nice photo of a sleeve
and also from round 3 so there are a lot
more photos from round 3 I will put a
link in the description below where you
can check out all of them from the
official 2013 candidates website but
until then let's check out this game so
good fun has the white pieces and he
opens with d4 Knight to f6
we have c4 e6 Knight to f3 and d5 so
transposing into the Queens gambit
declined Knight to c3 Knight B to d7
Bishop to g5 we have c6 e 3 and now
Carlsen goes for a very old line Queen
to a5 this is the Cambridge Springs
variation and if you've ever checked out
a book on the Queen's Gambit the client
or something that there's surely a whole
chapter about Cambridge Springs
variation and it's a really wild
variation if you're not ki if you're not
careful
things can get out of control very soon
for example in the game see captor Sundy
if I was played but I'm just gonna show
one variation just to show you how how
crazy things couldn't get straight out
of the opening for example if white were
to continue Bishop d3 let's say in 94
now we have Bishop captures pawn
captures now the knight is attacked if
you move the knight than Queen captures
Bishop on g5 so you have to go Knight to
e5 and now we have this f6 move and here
things really go crazy for example
Knight captures on b7 Queen captures on
g5
Queen to h5 check for a moment but now
Knight captures on f8 Queen captures and
g2 threatening to capture the rook but
now comes Queen to h5 check g6 and now
Knight captures on g6 Queen captures on
h1 King to d2 and Queen captures on a
one night capture Sun h8 this is a
discovered check King moves Knight of 7
check a king to c7 and here we have a
position where black is a body exchange
but clearly White has a White has a
better position the Queen can easily
come back to the Queen side and after
this is blocked come to a3 defend the b2
and then maybe even go to go to e7
all in all a better position for white
but just a taste of what this variation
can offer but in the game get one went
for seek after Sun d5 Knight captures on
d5 and rook to see one protecting the c3
Knight Knight captures pawn captures and
now Bishop to a 3 cross and attacks the
rook on c1 rook to c2 and now goes b6
preparing to develop the light square
bishop sorry as well Bishop to d3 286 we
have castles back elephant captures
captures and Carlson castles efore now -
prepares c5 - completely dominated the
center rook F to e 8 + e5 immediately
across and plays h6 a bishop to h4 and a
now c5 attacking - strong Center Knights
- D - preparing Knight to c4 pawn
captures pawn captures and now rook to
see it across and offers the exchange of
rooks Knight to c4
I wouldn't attack on the Queen and on
the bishop and now Queen to b5 there's
no danger of capturing the bishop as the
the night is now pin the Queen and d3 is
undefended
so first guys one goes f4 we have rook
to c7
Carlson is preparing to double up rooks
and the C file
Queen captures on a on a three row
captures on c4 rock across Queen
captures and Bishop to have to first
defending the d4 pawn it was under
attack we have Queen back to c7 by
Carson not defending the a 7 point
and look the c1 developing the rook also
would attempt on the Queen Queen to be
seven and now Queen to d6 a reasonable
move rock is coming to c7 disc the if if
course and allows this then he loses the
night and the game so first night to f8
you could go rook to see it immediately
but first cousin goes night to f8 from
there cousin is cross and is planning
that gelfand will at some point push f5
and when eek a person f5 Knight will
have a very nice outpost on e6 and get
fun first place g3
there's no y doesn't really gain
anything by Roxy 7 although it seems
like a very powerful move but after
Queen to a six a three
you can't allow like the capture the
pawn add then like and play simply rope
to c8 and then again all always well
cousin brings the Queen back into the
game and after g3 then it's actually
call since Queen that that infiltrates
the position so after night to a fate
first g3 by gelfand rook to c8 row
capture screen captures and now d5 so ok
it wasn't f5 it was d5 but still he
captures on d5 Queen captures and now g6
across in place g6 night will come here
and then the black king will be nicely
protected and the white king will be
somewhat somewhat more somewhat more
open kingi - we have Knights to e6 and
now Queen to f3 King the g7 and here a
three by Gelfand another idea was f5 but
the problem is after G capture screen
captures there's really nothing for this
Queen to do here after Queen to see for
attacking the a to pawn Queen f6 check
King moves you do win the H pawn but now
Queen captures on a2 and then you would
have to pass pawns on the Queen side and
this is a much red red greater advantage
than the past h1 on the Kings side so
after King g7 we have a three and here
we have h5 by Carson h4 Queen to c2
cling to b7 attacking the a7 pawn
and the now queen to a for defending the
pawn and attacking the a3 pawn queen to
f3 the Queen must go back to defend the
da tree pawn we have b5 now f5 finally
does come G capture screen captures and
now Queen captures on a3 Queen captures
on h5 and we go into a similar position
where cousin does have to pass pawns on
the Queen side and Geffen did manage to
open up Carson's King a bit and he has
an best H pawn we have a 5 Queen to g4
check King to f8 and now Caitlyn has to
make move 40 so he has to make one more
move before reaching time control and
he's in serious time trouble this is one
thing that was interesting about round
for round 3 that in every game one of
the players was in serious time trouble
so was gelfand in this game against my
cousin but it's very interesting that
Alexander grigio who was the world the
blitz champion always I mean he's a
world blitz champion obviously he's a
very very fast player but he always got
into time trouble well playing classical
chess so that that's pretty weird but
okay guys one has to make move number 40
to reach time control and he plays h5
Queen to h5 was a bit better you know
not changing the structure of the pawns
you know not having to decide anything
h5 was played and later after the game
they thought that this move was in fact
the move that game gave cause and some
practical chances cross in place Queen
to c1 we have Queen to e4 and now before
Carlsen starts pushing his Queen side
bones Bishop to e3 attacking the Queen
you could try Queen to a8 this does we
need the pawn but it loses the game in
g7 in Windhoek on b3 and then there's no
stopping b2 and b1
unfortunately for for white so after
before Bishop to e3 attacking the Queen
also this will be guarding the h6 square
when the point is pushed
quinta c7 Queen to 8 check we have King
to g7 and now h6 check King to h7 and
now we really don't have
don't have that much to do with White
Queen to b4 check was played King to g8
and now Queen back to a a check and now
if Carson would repeat King to h7 then
of course this could be offering a draw
by repetition but Carson doesn't play
this
he plays Queen to d8 and he offers a
trade of Queens and here you don't have
to trade Queens well better yet you
shouldn't trade Queens you should go
Queen to c6 and the thing is that white
white could actually stop the pawns for
example if cost and pushes b3 Bishop
comes here now Queen to b8 preparing to
pull the pawn king f1 now b2 and this is
the problem gets one probably so this
position in he he saw the move B to but
the thing is you can actually you can't
push B to hear you you have to bring the
Queen closer and then push the a pawn if
you play b2 here and capture with the
bishop then Queen captures on b2 doesn't
win the game for black it's actually
it's actually better for white now Queen
e8 check is coming now you can go to g7
the point is guarding the square you
have to move and then out comes Queen
captures on f7 check captures captures
and now it's actually two points the one
in favor of white so who knows why why
girlfriend didn't go into that variation
or or he saw that it doesn't work he saw
that to be two doesn't work you you
simply have to bring the Queen Yin will
blacken and pull the a pawn maybe even
that but okay he played Queen captures
Knight captures and now it's too passed
pawns on the Queen side for Carlson and
a passed h1 but it's a really advanced
best h1 it'd be it'd be much easier to
play this forget when if this pawn was
still on h4 if he didn't put that pawn
to h5 but he did have to reach down
control so he pushed it King to f3 we
have a 4 now King to e4 Knight to c6
Bishop to c1 Knight to a5 Bishop to d2
now attacking the b4 pawn now comes b3
of course you cannot capture the night
if you captured then b3 b2 end you can
stop the pond from queening so after b3
King to d3 in bringing the King closer
now comes
see 494 again you can't capture the
night if you capture the night and then
be - you can't stop the pond from
promoting so after night to see for that
we have Bishop to c3 and now a 3G for
King to h7 now g5 guarding the h6 pawn
Crossing place King to g6 we have Bishop
to d4 now comes b2 and King to c2 and
this is a beautiful position for you to
analyze and try try to find a move that
wins the game here for crossing just
pretty much only one move that that
surely wins the game
I feel free to pause it and it's not you
know you have to give it give it some
time you know don't rush it so I will
get a couple of seconds as usual for
those of you who were able to find the
winning move here congratulations you
are in excellent and game player and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
here cousin played nice to d2 and in
this position Boris Gelfand resigned at
the game if you found something like a -
of course this doesn't work because
Bishop simply captures and then you're
preventing i if not captures then the
king is also preventing the points so
not this after King's e2 night the d2
now of course the idea is b1 and this
this is winning the night is now
guarding the queening square of course
if you capture the night then you grab
another then you grab a queen that's
self-explanatory but the idea is after
Bishop captures now you have a capture
zombie - again you're threatening be one
Queen and if you capture the knight of
course you get another Queen so you have
to capture the pawn and now comes Knight
c4 check King c3 Knight captures on e5
and whatever you go king king d2 or
doesn't really matter the night will
come to f3 and then we'll pick up this
pawn and at some point you will simply
capture the h6 pawn and now it's a pawn
and the piece against the Barenaked King
a completely winning position for black
so yeah that the game didn't play out
all the way here after 92 get fun saw
that this is completely winning and he
resigned the game so yeah that's the
game
versus magnus carlsen from round three
of the 2013 candidates tournament i
would like to thank all of our gay and
you elastic for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
so Carson is now two out of three
drawing the first two games winning the
third game and will show at least one or
maybe two more games from round three
and then we'll talk a bit more about the
standings after round three so yeah once
again I do hope you enjoyed it as usual
you can check - on my previous video
Sierra thank you all for watching and
have an excellent rest of the Sunday
thank you